Hi good morning she good morning good morning and
Andthen
and today I'm going to talk in Portuguese a
little Spanish I'm also going to talk to
Felipe Brasil guy who lives here
Originally from Brazil a Moura in
Colombia in password on the internet
Portuguese if the  people who speak
spanish and happy good morning can you
explain a little more about your
channel on your channel yours is your channel
your channel without being that cool
stuff Thank you for the opportunity is here on
your channel Guys, you there who are
watching Steve's videos  You are
very well accompanied with her material it
is very good I follow it I have been following it for
more than ten years at least 10 years
I was at university when I even saw
the videos on the Internet and it was very cool so
basically I make the Internet
teach Portuguese  for people who have already
learned spanish listening to what i do
is like many
you must have heard it a
million times here in portuguese spanish is the
same thing right you don't need to learn it's
practice  just the same ok but if you
look for the differences you will find
many differences in the same way that if
you look for similarities you will
find many similarities in other
words if I want to tell Steve
that Portuguese Spanish very easy I
will look for all the similarities and I will
show you  look how easy it is see it's
the same thing now I'm going to put the
differences Then you put the words
but he Wow I don't know a word of
that and I have lists and more lists
here I've been that I can share
with the people there who  know Spanish that I
'm sure I wouldn't not know these
words which is very bad for me for
me it's very interesting because when
I decided it's IPCA to learn Portuguese
I bought a book about the differences
between Spanish and Portuguese the words
that change but and just not  was of no use and
did not act on Facebook
hi for me so my book already has mine
on because I am not native
Spanish for me it was too much  difficult
to move out of the spanish context
and enter the contest or is it portuguese and
to see o but for a person who speaks
spanish for example its the olympics
no how much time do you need to learn
p why you must communicate communicate can
click from principle to  speaking
Portuguese well How long does it take to speak?
People ask a lot about this, isn't it
Felipe, I already know Spanish, how long have I been
watching your videos to learn
Portuguese and everything will depend on how
long you've been in contact with the language and
not just how long
you're more the quality of the time you have
with the language because it's not the same thing if
you spend an hour reading a
grammar book and one
and on point you understand then but it's an hour
an hour but if you're putting
yours here  time on something that doesn't It's going to be
very positive, especially in the beginning, you
know, I don't see armadillo support
the idea of ​​you grammar grammar
grammar In the beginning I prefer that
students listen  there's a lot a lot a lot I
always talk about the four stages of
the learning process This is what I
talk about in the videos first stage understand
the second stage you say that what do you mean
talk later without how the baby
listens repeats right the third you read and
when you reach the last stage in
the written part you already have a
very high
vocabulary baggage, very significant.
depending on
how you invest that time, you know if
you're applying everything you've been talking about
in the digestive channel it's so
dry my channel also other
content creators who teach languages ​​in so much
good recommendation if you listen and
put it into practice with an hour a day
around in three months you have a good
level of Portuguese now it has to be
dedicated effectively now so
details like one thing is you pass  r
an hour Learning Portuguese and another
thing you spend an hour consuming
native content in Portuguese they are not
Portuguese classes it's like music video
so at least one hour consumed the
course content right
teaching material an hour teaching and everything
you can during the day  consuming the
content you are interested in in the language
you are learning Portuguese that's what I
said about the people that Colombia has not
It's just Colombia that is working
through the internet so there is one
in all countries where Portuguese is spoken
but they have a lot of
opportunity to  speaking in Portuguese
are people who live close
to Brazil what they have the possibility to
use if they spoke Portuguese or not
and I see that the big difference between
learning Portuguese in English which English
is is a language as a very commercial
language it is a language  that promises many
job opportunities to earn more money but
Portuguese I see as something more is the
reason you know it's like I met someone
I'm from Brazil I like the culture of Brazil
So what will make them
Practice the language here in Colombia is
meeting people in Brazil is welcoming
people and Brazil here in Colombia is
what will motivate them to learn
Portuguese it's not even that much  like it's not that
here we're close to the Border I
don't know that there's a border with Brazil there
's Tabatinga and you Letícia Tabatinga there
but it's a lot down there in Colombia, you
know so usually I see
people learning a language it's on their own
but of  it's the same reason it's like I know people
from Brazil I think the language is
a language that sounds very nice very
pleasant and there's something else that I
listen to in the municipality It's people who speak
here no I've tried to learn
English and it didn't work I'm bad at
preaching
and I never agree with that because it
's usually because the person used a
methodology more focused on grammar in the
beginning that explodes the person's head,
right, so I learned Portuguese with
that  methodology and then you come back
with English applying the same methodology, you
know, so I see that Portuguese is
something more like from within, the more heart
really I learned it because this is very
interesting because obviously it is
easier to learn by someone than speaking
Spanish is more  it will be easy to learn
Portuguese which is Lilac but if once
that person has learned Portuguese and
the gout is easier and it becomes
easier to improve their level in English
because the brain is already a little
tighter not bigger anymore  flexible has
more confidence that he can learn
another language so it may be that the
first step to learn is to
learn Portuguese and
Yes, it is true and the big limiting factor
that I see is because so many people have already
tried to learn English with this
methodology that many  sometimes you
don't like traditional and that
boring thing you don't have fun so whether
or not it creates a barrier for you to
learn other languages.  that you
think that all languages ​​will be the
same no I've already tried to learn
another language No it's not for me it doesn't
work for me until you see
someone learning the language because they
met someone or because they had the
opportunity to do something volunteering
in Brazil  to receive someone here in
Colombia and you see the passion for learning
and you learn with a smile on your face
here this is very important because
we also talked about the attitude,
you know, she has a good attitude for you to
learn the language as well that makes the
Total difference is that everything is very
important for him and we have to speak
Android in Spanish and you have the
Colombian accent, it doesn't stop for me to go, you know
there was a war but people
if someone who speaks Portuguese and who
learns Spanish and it's difficult to
want to change  If you're here, you're going to
speak either Spanish or you're just here
Brazilian Brazilian and I think it's the
same with Colombians that
learning Portuguese for example that you're going to
keep going  I'm just here,
it's not completely entering, it's not the
world of the Portuguese language, it's
cool I liked it, have you noticed this phenomenon
within your listeners?
I'm understood Ok so
I'm not going to make that much more effort to
learn the language, you know when you
start the police but the language is already like
a matter of whim, right? It's not
what I like to learn here.
to speak to the
point that people think I'm
from the country I have to speak Colombian consult they would
n't understand
easily But since I'm living
here and how you want Total immersion
when you talk when you like local things
Here people R lady like it is
funny like Wow, you talk about how
we are, it's even funny that in any
country you go to, at least the countries
I've been to, I'll talk about a man when
you mention an expression that's
very local  al People look at you
like yeah yeah where did you get that
word from whoever but that word
for you and you're going to say it's not that I
'm listening to the Globo podcast he said
such a thing I learned this expression I
wanted to use it now I'm
good  so here it happens a lot,
you know, so I see there are two
things talking about Brazilians, right,
Brazilians who are here in Colombia and
spend all their time with people from Brazil
and speak more Portuguese than Spanish and the
other thing of being content Not that it's
bad  so I have to settle for the level
there is like she already understands me So you don't
need to improve I'll go Ok man,
no problem You can talk
consult here without any problem
no one will be looking at you there
Wow, you're speaking with a non-Brazilian accent,
nothing, right  but it's really a
matter of whimsy sign i want to
polish it i want to say good to me
that i've always been fine but i'm also
going to let's go leave the link to the root of the
link in d  description just the link in the
description to your channel and that's it that's the
problem with the police I also wanted to
improve myself one day I've learned Portuguese to
polish it to be able to but I don't have time
because now I'm learning Hi bringing
the sea I wanted to do it because it's a  language is
a culture a country and not only Brazil is
also very fond of Portugal is another
its is burning is a culture music
many things own is a thing want
good is a day good day a day the time Norma
now a recommendation I give  for the
people who are learning other
languages ​​on your channel through your
platform, it's also that you
have to get to the point of the language that
you don't feel anymore you're taking classes in
that language see you're living the language
you understand you're like your language  native
you don't get home at night I'm
Brazilian I get home at night I
don't know man I practiced a lot of Portuguese
today it's not your native language
got it so you have to take the
foreign language that you are
learning to this point that it is so
common in your day to day life that you don't even
feel like you're going to be studying that you
're there like
I was I have everything in English man
everything in English my computer all the
whole screen is only I can speak English  It's in
English when I call support
Spanish option Robson in Portuguese
English option In English this is all English So
for me I don't feel like I'm
studying in English this is what it's like it
's part of my life I wasn't even
paying attention to it  I'm practicing
every day and that's it helps a lot
you find points for you to
tie yourself understand pay you I found
a point that I think I like a lot Ah
I found a book that I like a lot it
's a program that I like a lot so
you  go there consume this content
more often right that's that's the
goal the goal no I don't know about that it's the goal
it's not because yes the goal is the goal
without you are in contact with the
frequent language nice to meet you very much
let's have dinner with you
here guys who are watching this video
don't forget that in the
And then in the video description it's dry
also leave information is on Instagram
and other times the cariocas will leave it
here on yes
and sometimes I'm very surprised because
because there are a lot of Brazilians who watch
my videos and I talk to her what you
're doing here on the channel he says it's not
that I'm learning Spanish
the aggressive
way Portuguese  in Portuguese And the
wife not if he's teaching it in
Portuguese it's because I should learn
this Spanish They look for that word
in Spanish too and there are
many tips there too many tips there that I learned
during this time learning languages ​​with
I was with and I also steal that is  a guy
who didn't become an English teacher on the
internet I learned a lot with him
on the platform as I told you so there are
many things that are on the channel that  and the
people can take advantage of it to increase the
level is the idea that you have fun
through the process This is the great
objective Alright so if you are,
thanks to the church for the opportunity to
be here shared asked and exchanged
some ideas I had a lot of fun here and
we will  be there for the next beauty
success of the channel
Eai Eai
[Music]